hello everybody hope that you're good
today's Monday is the start of the new
trading week and this week I have a
feeling that is going to be quite
complex okay because we have a lot of
economic data coming out we have non
fund payrolls unemployment rate coming
on Friday JS opening survey Jon pow also
speaking be careful okay my experience
Instinct uh feeling call it as you want
it tells me that it could be a week with
a lot of traps liquidity grabs stop
hunts be careful okay so the first thing
that I'm going to say is that this week
I'm going to play with a smaller size
than useful I don't want to risk as much
as ual um still I see some setups that
developing that I want to pay attention
to and because I think that this week is
going to be a week that we're going to
all the time try to get stop Huns and
liquidity grabs we have to try to figure
out where the liquidity is because we're
want to see do stones getting hit all
the time um if you notice here we've had
this sideways move for a week uh yes
exact exactly for a week and if you
notice this zellow line here I talked
about this yesterday in the Sunday
update on XO I want to refresh a couple
of things this Yow line it's a a strong
resistance you can see how it gets
tested once twice three times almost
four times so of course course above
this line here there is going to be a
lot of stop losses okay uh to me that's
a very clear area of liquidity not of
liquidations again but of stop losses I
mean probably some liquidations too but
mainly stop losses there is going to be
a lot of stop losses sitting above this
area okay and thinking that that's
correct that there is liquidity there
then of course uh price is going to go
towards this area and if it does so then
we can situ scenarios the first one is a
push up consolidating above it holding
this area that is telling you that it
was not a sweep of the highs and there
is going to be continuation to the
upside to
74,000 because we saw that in the
liquidation hit M High block Capital
there is liquidity at this area and that
basically matches with this projection
that I've been talking about for a
couple of weeks okay so that's the first
scenario and the other scenario is a
push up towards this area hit all these
liquidations come back lower again below
this line tested a resistance
consolidation below resistance and that
is telling you that all this was was a
stop hunt a liquidity grab and price is
going to continue dropping and ranging
okay or even going for the lows so those
are the two setups that I am thinking
that we can see in this line over there
so that's a couple of triggers that you
can pay attention to and trade based on
that if you trade based on reaction and
the other one is this area here that's
the current H low of this range okay of
course below this level here there is
also going to be a lot of stop losses
because any
Trader that it's longing in this area
here has placed a stop loss right below
this line so it wouldn't surprise me at
all that if this week is going to be
quite trixy that we see first something
like this okay a sweep of the lows get
back above this line tested a support
and that would be the basically an entry
Trigger or an entry signal to go long
because the most likely thing is that
then they're going to be aiming for the
liquidity above the range SI so I would
love to see this s the first but I'm not
sure if that's going to happen because
we are right now above the 4H hour 50 Ma
and you can see that we are testing it
as support for a couple of times so as
long as we hold Above This level then we
could continue going up so pay attention
to this okay if you start to
lose this level here the 4 15ma then we
have to pay attention to this sweep of
the lows get back up above the the lows
above support and then that will be an
entry to go long aiming for this area
above the rain size okay okay so that's
a couple of setups there to keep an eye
on now how am I trading this well I'm
not trading it on bitcoin okay I'm
keeping eye on bitcoin because Bitcoin
is going to tell me what is going to
happen in the market because all the
coins follow Bitcoin altcoins ethereum
they follow Bitcoin so of course Bitcoin
is the main chart that I keep our
attention to but I want to talk you
about ethereum okay if you look at
ethereum ethereum um I'm going to
explain to you what these lines are
these are the lines that the retail
Trader is probably drawing and why do I
draw them because it's important to know
what they're thinking the first line
well let me remove that so you can see
more clearly we had this train line here
you can see how it was
support all this time now when this
happens it's very normal to see uh
basically a drop or liquidity grab below
the trend line to hit all the stop
losses and that's basically what
happened in this area here okay so this
area here that I'm marking right now
that is pretty much what we saw a
liquidity grab so I was expecting that
that's what I didn't want to go along
here and I wanted to see this this here
first all right then I went long at this
area then I closed the the long here
that was a scalp that I did last night
and now if you notice there is a new
trend line developing here
that is that one so the question is are
we going to see the same happening to
this trend line or are we actually going
to see some
consolidation between this support and
this resistance with the 4our 50a also
helping a support and then an upside
move that's what I'm keeping an I on to
see that's what I have this trend lines
here uh to see basically H to give me
some idea
um the way that I'm going to trade this
is basically I'm going to be trading
ethereum um I did this last night um
today I'm going to do the same and I'm
going to explain to you why if you
notice ethereum
is 15% away from the highs okay if you
go to
bitcoin Bitcoin is
only 6% away from the highs so you can
see the difference right
now if Bitcoin goes up or the markets go
up ethereum has a lot more rewards than
Bitcoin because there is a lot more
imbalances and area to recover the
reason why ethereum has dropped more and
it's recovering the slower is because
the ethereum Bitcoin pair okay um take
this as the dominance of Bitcoin um on
ethereum you can see this drop on the
ethereum Bitcoin pair and that's why
ethereum has under perform versus
Bitcoin all right now if you go into the
daily time frame you can see that this
is somewhat of a range here that's your
range highs a couple of deviations quite
normal this your range lows another
deviation normal but right now we are at
support we're at the range low so why
not why couldn't start to go again
towards the range highs because if you
notice they just playing ping and pong
here drop up go up drop up up well kind
of drop go up drop up drop up you know
what I mean right so why not what
couldn't start to see in ethereum
Bitcoin pair I start to see again this
kind of upside move that we see so
frequently and then that takes me to
lower time frame 4 hours time frame and
what I saw here is this
week you can see this week over here
marked by the Euro line wi F strategy
tells me that this week gets filled um
it go fill the 50% still price went back
lower and at this point is telling you
that they're going to go lower they're
going to go for the 100% fill because
there is no reason why this would
revisit this level and this basically
because they want to continue filling
the week so it goes to the 100% of the
week sweep of the lows then retest of
support perfect and right now we have to
see what it does but this could be a
beautiful reversal pattern in the
ethereum Bitcoin pair we want to start
seeing again something like this okay A
bit of consolidation here above the 4H
hour 50 Ma and maybe that's when the
momentum can change and we can start to
see something like that now if that is
the case that's what takes me to the
ethereum um USD pair and I'm drawing
this uh ID okay of seeing ethereum going
higher of course for that we need
Bitcoin to go up too but in the case
that we think that the market can go up
then why not trade ethereum if it's
going to give us a better setup a better
reward so how am I trading this well if
you want to play super careful what I
would tell you is to enter here at this
trigger here because of course you have
here strong
resistance and the safest entry would be
to enter to enter at the flip of this
resistance into support so if we see I
move to the upside and then I retrace
and we hold this support that's what you
could be entering for continuation okay
that would be the safest entry but um I
like to trade an entry at different
stages okay uh with different orders
that's the way I usually play okay so
instead what I'm doing is I'm keeping a
big size order there there well is I'm
not putting a limit order I
trade uh when I see the price action
doing what I want so if I enter there
maybe I'm entering a resistance okay if
I P limit order so no first I want to
see this move and then the retrace and
that's when I enter because again if you
P limit order then it's going to get
trigger when it hits resistance and then
you can see the drop so that's the
importance of at least for me having
some screen time and being able to see
to tell what I enter so that's my bigger
entry is going to be there because it's
the safest entry but then I'm thinking
about other entries and well let me
remove this trend line let's play with
this one because I guess that's what the
retail is doing they've changed the
trend line you know how they are if the
tra line gets broken they find another
one so this is so far what everybody is
looking at okay I imagine it's very
possible that if Bitcoin because again
this depends only of Bitcoin if Bitcoin
drops here to this uh to the range lows
to the liquidity below the range
lows then ethereum will do the same
ethereum will take the liquidity the
stop losses below this trend line This
ones okay and that could drop I don't
know tell me about it it could even drop
here towards this level here okay around
3,400 key for take and that would be a
place where again depending on what
Bitcoin does I would enter ethereum for
example I'm going to give you some ideas
if Bitcoin does this this drop first and
then we see Bitcoin doing this okay
recovering the range testing a support
that's what I would enter in ethereum
that will be my entry in ethereum and I
don't know if that would be a 3,400
3,380 3,420 I don't know but I guess
around this area so that would be what I
would enter now there is another chance
and is that
Bitcoin goes a straight away instead of
doing
that to the range highs which I think so
far we have the
advantage of testing the 4H hour 50ms
support so I believe that it's more
likely that we do that next okay that we
go to the range size based on
probabilities so going back to the 30
chart let me remove
this in etherum we are also above the 4
or 50 m right now and this trend line is
support so I've already entered here
I've already entered just right before
starting to film this video I have an
entry on ethereum I'm on the trade and
I'm going to see if this can happen
first okay if this happens then I'm
going to enter again with a bigger size
order and my take profits is going to be
around this area because I can see here
this liquidity pool over
there all right so that will be my take
profits there that is how I'm playing
the the charts today and I don't think I
could have been clearer and in a more
transparent way than this do you know my
triggers my setup if I'm in a position
or not I am small size again I repeat if
you want to play and enter here small
size and then once you see this you can
enter with bigger size because you're
going to be in a much safer environment
to trade okay because you're want to see
that that retrace and
continuation and if you enter here with
bigger size instead I think it's a bad
idea because we also have uh some
probabilities of Bitcoin dropping the
range lows take that liquidity eum doing
the same and then here you're going to
lose money all right and if I think what
the chances of
Bitcoin doing one thing of the other
just because we are above the four or 50
may I give this uh
60% and this idea at 40% of
probabilities it's very even at the
moment okay that's why if you want to
trade now you have to be very careful
don't enter with bigger size just now
wait for something more clear all right
I don't care if you trade ethereum
Bitcoin Pepe just be careful okay
because Capital preservation is very
important anyway um I think I'm going to
wrap this video here I'm not going to go
through the liquidation hit mask because
I saw that yesterday in the on Twitter
well on X and nothing has really changed
in the 7 Days time frame you're going to
see in the liquidation hit Maps the
liquidity at this area here and the
liquidity in this area here because
that's what the chart is showing the
highs the lows you know what I say and
in the order book uh it's pretty much
quite even also okay so I think that's
pretty much everything that I want to
say oh yes by the way on Saturday that
was uh two days ago we published on our
website cob.com
the new courses so you can book the
course for the next course is the 15 of
April um we've already sold almost 50%
of all the places there are still some
places there so you can go to the
website book your place and you get a
straightway added to the telegram
Channel where we'll have the the course
okay so in case any of you are
interested and missed out do you still
have the chance to to join the course
okay so anyway thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you
[Music]
soon